bonjour bienvenue dans ces caches une
fois n'est pas coutume je commencerai
par une phrase de michel houellebecq le
monde d'après ce sera le monde d'avant
empire
bonjour aujourd'hui nous allons vous
parler du monde d'après on joue à
estelle lieu dans ces caches on en a
beaucoup parlé un du monde d'après
comment à la crise du coronavirus at
elle modifié nos modes de consommation
quand peut-on s'attendre à une vraie
reprise économique quelle leçon doit-on
tirer de cette crise ce sont toutes ces
questions qui vont nous occuper olivier
apens dans ce numéro
et puis en deuxième partie pour en
parler nous serons en liaison avec jean
marie daniel économiste et professeur à
le s&p europe mais d'abord olivier pour
les dix est un terme qui est beaucoup
revenu le monde d'après alors il ya d'un
côté ceux qui estiment que la pandémie
va accélérer les révolutions des gens
déjà entamée d'autres y voient un moyen
de rupture totale avec le passé et puis
il ya ceux qui pensent que cela ne va
rien changer vous olivier dans quel camp
vous situez vous ça me paraît difficile
d'imaginer un monde totalement différent
on voit d'ailleurs que ils réagissent
exactement comme d'habitude que ce soit
les banques centrales d'ailleurs où les
gouvernements ils réagissent exactement
comme d'habitude c'est à dire qu'ils
font tourner la planche à billets et qu'
ils font de la baie donc ils n'ont
jamais changé
ils n'ont jamais eu ni des autres que ça
donc je vois pas très bien la différence
avec les autres
les autres traitements de crise la seule
chose que je vois et ça malheureusement
ça n'évolue pas en mieux mais en pire
c'est la suppression rapide d'un
ensemble de liberté c'est à dire qu'on
se retrouve quand même sous prétexte de
ce virus pendant deux mois et demi on se
retrouve en résidence surveillée quand
vous sortez et bien vous avez une amende
maintenant on va vous imposer le port du
masque parce que paraît-il y'en à moi
j'en ai pas encore trouvé mais enfin bon
il paraît qu'il y en a
alors qu'il ya quelques semaines encore
c'était absolument pas nécessaire et
maintenant vous allez avoir une amende
si vous emportez pas enfin on voit que
les choses ne vont pas mieux on vote des
lois sans arrêt pour nous mais un peu
plus de liberté et donc je vois pas
franchement une amélioration des choses
je pense que ça sert de prétexte pour
passer beaucoup de bêtises un mot sur la
consommation à la france est donc d
confiné depuis le 11 mai alors il ya des
règles à respecter en notamment dans les
commerces des temps distanciation
asocial port du masque parfois elles
s'ajoutent à ça la crainte du virus et
la crainte d'une possible contamination
la consommation des ménages devrait
décrocher de 7 5% cette année selon le
cabinet d'études xerfi
la pandémie at-elle sonné la fin de la
consommation d'avant liés aux coûts t on
verra bien on a pu aussi une queue pas
possible devant les magasins zara
magasin de vêtements est il donc que des
gens qui apparemment avait hâte de
consommer donc je ne sais pas ce que ce
qui se passera je pense que xerfi n'en
sait pas plus que moi sur le la baisse
de la consommation
je pense que de toute façon il y aura
une baisse de la consommation pour la
bonne et simple raison que les gens
n'ont plus de sous donc il en avait pas
beaucoup parents ils en ont encore moins
maintenant et donc évidemment ça pèsera
sur le la consommation d'après merci à
vos colis vient on passe tout de suite à
la deuxième partie de cette émission
et nous sommes en liaison avec jean marc
daniel économiste et professeur à le scp
europe
bonjour jean marc daniel bonjour merci à
beaucoup de participer à cette émission
alors jean marc daniel je voudrais pour
commencer une réaction une réaction ce
sondage selon une enquête de
l'observatoire cetelem
57% des français considèrent que
beaucoup de choses vont changer dans
leur mode de vie après le confinement et
les 43 % restants envisage plutôt cette
période comme une simple parenthèse
selon vous il y aura-t-il un monde
d'après vous au contraire pensez vous
que la pandémie ne va rien changer du
tout oui je suis plutôt dans le camp de
ceux qui pensent que la pandémie va pas
avoir changé fondamentalement les règles
du jeu et les règles de la vie
quotidienne il ya trois raisons à ça la
première raison c'est quand même con me
disent des économistes que c'est un choc
exogène c'est quelque chose qui est
arrivé de l'extérieur il traduit pas une
défaillance du système économique
capitaliste mondialisé dans lequel nous
vivons
la deuxième chose qui paraît intéressant
dans ce qui se passe c'est que les gens
n'ont pas consommé parce que les
magasins étaient fermés mais il a changé
un peu ce que vient dire olivier c'est à
dire qu on sait pas très bien quelle va
être leur comportement mais on voit bien
il ya des queues devant les magasins de
textile il ya des queues devant les
coiffeurs c'est important d'avoir une
coiffure
propre mais cet engouement pour la pour
les magasins est un engouement qui
traduit le fait que les gens ont envie
de consommer et qu' il ya eu une forme
de
de thésaurisation qui est apparue il ya
55 milliards d'argent thésauriser
d'après la banque de france sur les
comptes courants est sûre et livrés à
des ménages et les gens dès qu'ils
pourront les utiliser je pense vont
essayer de les utiliser et le troisième
élément est alors là je rejoins quand
même ce que vient de dire olivier il ya
un problème d'approvisionnement balle
pendant deux mois on n'a pas travaillé
en france pendant deux mois dans
beaucoup de pays effectivement
l'activité a été sinon à l'arrêt du
moins profond recul et donc je pense que
cet appauvrissement va avoir des
conséquences sur le niveau de vie
immédiat des des français et de
l'ensemble du monde qui a été confiné
jeudi vient du monde parce que l'inde a
été confiné la chine a été confiné à
certains moments donc ce manque de
travail va se faire sentir parce que il
faut quand même avoir conscience que la
richesse est la source de la richesse
c'est pas la dette qu'on est en train
d'accumuler c est la capacité que l'on a
à travailler pour fournir des biens et
des services
alors justement olivier jean marc veya
l'évoquer en ses 55 milliards d'euros
d'épargné forcée ça fait 230 euros en
moyenne par semaine selon les
estimations de l'observatoire français
des conjonctures économiques
et ce qu'olivier c'était par une force
et pourrait faire office de moteur pour
la consommation est ce que cela pourrait
s que ça pourrait suffire à amortir la
récession mais pas du tout parce que je
pense que c'est 55 milliards vont pas se
retrouver dans la consommation d'abord
2,55 milliards pouvez vous les garder
parce que très très probablement l'état
va nous payer un impôt d'ici la fin de
l'année et va les bouffer les 55
milliards donc très franchement je
serais les gens qui ont épargné ses 55
milliards je les garderai bien au chaud
parce que ils vont se retrouver taxes et
donc que non moi je pense que
contrairement à un jean n'a cessé
réellement aujourd'hui pas un choc
exogène comme il dit c'était une
récession et un ralentissement qui est
déjà là le virus a servi de catalyseur
mais les problèmes étaient déjà là les
problèmes
le gilet jaune saad a pas de virus
c'était bien avant donc on avait un
souci entre l'économie réelle et ce
qu'ils étaient traduits dans la finance
et ce qu'ils étaient traduits dans la
bourse
on avait une bulle d'un côté qui ne
correspondait à rien et absolument à
rien vis-à-vis versus l'économie réelle
et une économie réelle qui est dans la
panade
alors le virus est venu là dessus comme
déclencheur et comme catalyseur comme
amplificateur mais en aucun cas c'est le
leu leu leu réellement la cause de ceux
de sète de cette profonde récession et
on a des gens qui ont réagi exactement
pomme il avait réagi en 2008 comme il
avait réagi en 2001 comme ils ont réagi
en 91
c'est à dire avec les mêmes méthodes on
endette on fait tourner la planche à
billets et je ne vois pas aujourd'hui
que les choses soient comparables
on est là dans un choc d'offre et de
demande avec une production qui s'est
arrêtée dans beaucoup de pays
prince a quasiment le pib mondial s'est
arrêté pendant quelque temps et et on le
traite comme si on avait une crise est
comme celle de 2008
parce qu on appelle ça la grande
réception d'agde et c'était de récession
concernés de trimestre avec un recul de
2%
faut arrêter un tout petit peu de 2 pour
parer des choses qui sont pas
comparables jean marie danielle une
réponse à ce qui marche
oui mais il rejoint plutôt ce que je dis
c'est à dire que c'est un choc exogène
c'est quelque chose qui est une
situation inédite on voit bien que
pendant les mois de confinement en
france le taux d'utilisation des
capacités de production était de 50 à 55
% alors que dans les récessions
précédentes
utilisation des capacités de production
étaient descendus aux alentours de 75 %
dans cette situation est une situation
totalement inédite est aberrante et elle
va se corriger assez vite le plus vite
on remettra le pays au travail
le mieux ça vaudra c'est à dire que le
dôme de confinement doit être accélérée
comme il est dans un certain nombre
d'autres pays en revanche là où je
rejoins olivier ses rangs le fait que
les gouvernements qui dans la situation
actuelle sont manifestement dépassés par
les évènements ne répondent que par les
outils traditionnels des années
précédentes et des récessions
précédentes au travers d'une
augmentation de la dette
et ça ça va avoir un avis de conséquence
la première effectivement les français
commencent à s'inquiéter on le voyait
déjà auparavant sur la façon dont va
être géré cette dette et la deuxième
c'est que il n'est pas impossible vu le
financement de cette dette qu'on ait une
poussée d'inflation
on commence à voir des prix qui ont
considérablement augmenté dans le
secteur où les magasins étaient ouverts
c'est à dire l'agroalimentaire et pour
en revenir au coiffeur toutes les
personnes qui sont allées voir un
coiffeur sur les deux derniers jours
savent bien que les prix du coiffeur on
aurait augmenté donc je pense que le
véritable enjeu c'est la façon dont les
gouvernements vont pouvoir imaginer le
retour à la production traditionnelle en
effaçant les conséquences en termes de
dettes et de politique monétaire de la
décision qu'ils ont prise
alors justement à jean-daniel vous
évoquez les outils traditionnels mise en
place quels outils aurait-il fallu
mettre en place alors je pense qu'il y
avait deux enjeux la première chose qui
était le degré de confinement et le
degré que l'on imposé la population de
restriction de liberté
là aussi olivier l'a dit il ya quand
même eu ce que la prise de pouvoir parce
que j'appelais dans certains articles de
presse complexe médico technocratique
c'est à dire des gens qui de l'extérieur
au nom d'une science est de savoir que
manifestement il maîtrisait assez mal
des gens dont qui ont imposé des
restrictions à nos libertés et donc je
pense que ça n'a pas été la même chose
dans tous les pays l'exemple que l'on
met en avant assez souvent c'est celui
de la suède
on le voit bien aussi dans aux états
unis où tous les états n'ont pas eu le
même comportement est donc
je pense que dans cet état d'esprit qui
était celui qui était d'actualité - de
la libération il faut mobiliser au
maximum les capacités du travail c'est à
dire il faut que localement entreprise
par entreprise se négocient des accords
visant à augmenter la durée du temps de
travail à revenir sur les rtt préparer
effectivement une reprise en main
complète de l'appareil de production
oui une réaction à ces outils au québec
et jean marc daniel écoutez je pense que
malheureusement en effet c'est la
population qui va payer les bêtises on
fait les les gouvernements encore une
fois on dirait y sont responsables de
rien ils sont coupables de rien c'est
selon la grande tradition et nous allons
payer nous allons payer sous forme
d'impôts nous allons payer sous forme de
suppression de liberté nous allons payer
sur pour ceux qui se croyaient encore en
démocratie nous n'y sommes plus depuis
un moment donc peu leur c'est venu c'est
devenu un cauchemar ce qui est en train
de se passer il faudrait que les gens se
réveillent
parce que il faut d'urgence changer les
équipes en place qui sont qui ont
démontré leur incompétence et qui ont
démontré une sale habitude de mettre
tout le monde sous coupe réglée
messieurs on va faire une courte pause
on revient dans un instant bienvenue
dans ces caches si vous nous rejoignez
on parle du monde d'après avec gens
vendent daniel économiste et professeur
à escp europe
alors messieurs je voudrais que l'on
s'intéresse à ce texte de patrick artus
économiste en chef de la banque
d'investissement natixis ce texte il a
été publié sur le site de la banque
selon patrick artus la crise du coït 19
pourrait sonner le glas du capitalisme
néolibéral
selon ce texte les conséquences de la
crise serait un le retour à des chaînes
de valeur
journal de la fin de l'austérité
budgétaire et de la concurrence fiscale
3 une volonté des états de développer
nationalement les industriels
stratégiques et enfin la compréhension
de ce qu'il faut que toute la population
bénéficie d'une protection sociale
convenable
est ce que vous êtes d'accord est ce la
fin de cette forme de capitalisme jean
marc daniel ah non pas du tout je pense
que l'analyse de patrick artus est un
peu dans l'air du temps c'est assez à la
mode 2d danser le capitalisme néolibéral
mais je pense que ce capitalisme c'est à
dire la capacité des individus à
s'organiser et pas en cause en revanche
ce qui est en cause c'est la façon dont
l'état s'est comportée et je pense que
ce qui est plutôt menacé ces états
providence pléthorique immense qui n'ont
pas été capables de nous protéger
en revanche ce qui m'inquiète de façon
très claire c'est que derrière tous ces
discours sur la relocalisation à la fin
du capitalisme néolibéral et tout ça il
ya d'appel retour au protectionnisme et
là aussi si jamais on remettait en place
des situations de protectionnisme de
repli sur soi le pouvoir d'achat de la
population serait encore plus affectées
c'est dire qu'on aura déjà des tensions
liées à l'appauvrissement du à deux mois
d'arrêt de l'activité et si en plus on
remet en place du protectionnisme ça va
encore aggraver la situation
donc concrètement c'est plus une façon
de répondre à des slogans à la mode que
d'une analyse à mon avis véritablement
réel de ce qui peut nous arriver
olivier ça va très bien aussi je
commenterai pas les analyses de patrick
artus
ça n'a pas grand intérêt mais là le ski
et ce qui est intéressant c'est de voir
alors je moi je sus je suis assez pour
tout de même qu' il ya un certain nombre
de choses qui changent sur les sur les
années à venir mais il faudrait d'abord
les équipes changent vous le dis parce
que sinon ça ne servira à rien mais en
effet à à un protectionnisme mais un
souverainisme et un protectionnisme
quand elle est intelligente ça peut
servir si on hamm est
fermer les frontières aux virus
ça aurait été intéressant alors on l'a
fait mais on l'a fait trop tard les
allemands l'ont fait avant nous et ils
ont fermé les frontières et alors je
sais pas si ça s'appelle du
protectionnisme mais en tout cas ça
s'appelle un acte intelligent ce qu'on a
été incapable évidemment de faire donc
maintenant je pense que il faut revenir
non pas à ce qui est en train d'être
fait je le disais dans la dernière
émission qui est une espèce de
soviétisation des économies où l'état
prend des parts dans les entreprises en
difficulté sais c'est pas du capitalisme
cdu c'est du socialisme pur et dur
bon on sent qu'ils tissent en fait
l'économie
les économies occidentales et bientôt
vous recevrez tous votre feuille de
salaire directement du gouvernement donc
on est dans quelque chose qui n'a rien à
voir avec le capitalisme pour l'instant
et qui va pas dans une direction qui me
paraît souhaitable
jean magalhaès qu'il faudrait s'engager
dans la voie de la nationalisation à non
surtout pas
joint ce lundi olivier c'est à dire que
la nationalisation et l'idée qu'il ya
derrière de relocalisation encore une
fois c'est une démarche qui consiste à
rando moins efficace l'appareil
productif donc à ponctionner sur le
pouvoir d'achat de la population et la
population n'attend pas ça c'est dire
que la population et ça ça va être une
des conséquences de cette crise la
population a pris l'habitude aussi de
s'organiser différemment des grands à
mon avis élément qui va conditionner le
retour à l'activité normale ça va être
l'utilisation du télétravail crois que
beaucoup d'entreprises ont découvert
entre pression de ses deux mois de
confinement qu' il pouvait s'organiser
différemment elle pouvait faire des
gains de productivité et qu'elle pouvait
effectivement évolué à condition d'être
en contact direct avec les legends h et
qui qui travaille chez elles et donc je
pense que les grands perdants de ça
c'est l'état les grandes bureaucraties
syndicales et tous les gens qui rêvent
de relocalisation et de nationalisation
le modèle de la pologne des années 70 un
peu évoquée par olivier dans lequel
effectivement l'état s'occupe de tout
mais on a comme résultat des queues
devant les magasins son modèle là est à
mon avis un des grands perdants de ce
qu'il vient de se passer
jean marc daniel un mot sur cette
tribune a publié le 14 avril dernier
dans laquelle un collectif de 181
personnalités politiques chefs
d'entreprises et dirigeants à des ong
ont appelé à une relance verte
européenne la lutte contre le changement
climatique doit être au coeur du moteur
économique et le temps de la mise en
oeuvre est venu faut-il une relance
verte européenne
non c'est à dire qu'on a assisté à
l'occasion de cette crise retour de tous
les poncifs chacun essaie de refiler ses
idées et donc on à la relance verte on a
aussi le retour de lier cf qui fait une
une percée sur le plan médiatique je
pense que l'enjeu n'est pas là l'enjeu à
court terme c'est de remettre le pays au
travail et à moyen terme de se poser des
questions en terme de
résorption de toute cette dette et de
tout ce système qui était un système qui
n'a eu comme seule capacité de réaction
que de menacer l'avenir par une
accumulation d'être crois qu'il ya un
vrai question qui se pose par delà la
relance verte c'est une question de
rapports intergénérationnels c'est dire
que on critique la situation en termes
d'écologie au nom de la préservation de
la planète et de ce qu'on va laisser à
nos enfants mais il faut voir qu'on va
leur laisser aussi un paquet de dette
on va leur laisser aussi une économie
qui n'a pas voulu faire les réformes
qu'elle devait faire pour améliorer sa
productivité et donc c'est pas la
relance verte qui doit être l'enjeu
c'est une réflexion intergénérationnel
sur qu'est-ce qu'on laisse à nos
héritiers qu'est-ce qu'on laisse à nos
enfants
est-ce que c'était légitime de laisser
ce paquet de dette avec comme objectif
ce qui était louable mais qui était
quand même assez ciblées de préserver la
vie des plus à des plus âgés donc il ya
une vraie question qui doit se poser et
non pas retournés et revenir sur les
poncifs habituels c'est à dire
l'économie décarbonée le retour au local
remettre lisf davantage de dialogue
social
l'amour de son prochain et c'est toutes
ces idées un peu convenue et plus ou
moins farfelues l'icône terme au nez
tout ça à mon avis doit être évacué je
suis pas tout à fait d'accord avec avec
jean-marc sur sur les relocalisations je
pense au contraire qu'il faudrait
réfléchir au modèle économique qu'on a
le modèle de spécialisation économique
de nom diversification et le modèle qui
abandonnent complètement l'industrie
pour le tertiaire et cetera je pense pas
que ce soit une bonne solution
pensons au contraire que les pays
devraient tous viser une certaine
autonomie à une autonomie complète parce
que ça évidemment c'est impossible mais
une certaine autonomie et on met les
moyens de de notre autonomie sur notre
sol je pense que là où l'a bien vu
d'ailleurs avec notre incapacité à
fabriquer des masques incapacité à se
fournir
honte est ce qu'un incapacité à 1 et
donc une attente en deux
à part de pays lointains la chine par
exemple un pour nous fournir des
matériaux de première nécessité donc je
pense qu'au contraire relocaliser un
certain nombre de choses qui nous assure
une indépendance 1 me paraît vital la
france est agréable ont les moyens de se
réindustrialiser et de reproduire
localement on a les moyens si on se les
six onces les donne il a je vois on se
dirige vers ça donc que je vous dis on
est en train de traiter ce qui est en
train de se passer de façon tout à fait
traditionnelle donc qu'est-ce qu'on fait
ben on en baisse donc on augmente les
impôts on fait marcher la planche à
billets parce que c'est quand même ce
qui est facile et on se pose aucune
question sur justement est-ce que ce
modèle qui ne repose que sur la dette
et ça et cela depuis un bon moment mais
je parle amis on à france là je parle
des états unis c'est pareil je parle de
d'autres parties dans le dans le monde
le japon la chine est là qui font très
exactement tous la même chose au même
moment avec les mêmes recettes et etc
des recettes dont on sait très bien
depuis un bon bout de temps
elle ne fonctionne pas mais on continue
à les faire mais jean marie danielle
pour terminer à quelle leçon à doit-on
tirer de cette crise
welch racaille il ya trois leçons très
rapide a tiré la première leçon c'est
effectivement ce que vient de dire
olivier c'est le désarroi ambiant le
désarroi de l'ensemble et dirigeants qui
n'ont répondu que par cette facilité
qu'ils ont acquise avec la fin de la
référence hors de la monnaie de faire
marcher la planche à billets et donc je
crois que
les gens qui nous dirigent sont limités
dans leur capacité de réaction et donc
il faut que les gens apprennent
l'habitude aussi de se prendre mal le
deuxième élément qui est assez important
c'est que je pense que fondamentalement
le travail organisée autour du
télétravail organisé auto la
réorganisation très local des choses est
plus que jamais d'actualité et le
troisième élément c'est cette menace
pour moi qui reste une menace c'est à
dire de vouloir préserver l'outil au nom
d'une forme de souveraineté un outil de
production au moins deux chocs
pétroliers on avait constaté qu'on avait
pas de pétrole et que la seule solution
c'était d'avoir des idées
je pense que sur globalement les
éléments que nous avons en main il faut
mieux se spécialiser dans les idées que
d'essayer de reconstituer du pétrole que
de toute façon nous n'avons pas merci
beaucoup à vous joindre daniel d'avoir
participé à cette émission et je
rappelle que vous êtes économiste et
professeur à lui s & p europe
merci on passe aux questions qui fâchent
olivier c'est l'heure des questions cash
olivier alors je vous rappel avant tout
que vous pouvez à poser vos questions à
olivier delamarche sur les réseaux
sociaux
il y répondra dans cette émission a si
votre question est sélectionné alors
olivier on passe tout de suite à la
première question aux fins de questions
qui se ressemblent et visiblement elle
les internautes ont besoin d'un peu plus
de précisions à ce sujet fabienne devos
bonjour j'aurais juste une question le
monde entier à une dette colossale mais
envers qui et puis à behind aux écoles
de recrues la bce n'est débitrice de
rien du tout elle n'a pas de créanciers
donc il s'agit d'une dette vis-à-vis de
qui fait quoi olivier alors les dettes
sont détenus
ça dépend des pays si nous prenez la
grèce
ces détenus par les entités européennes
et donc qu' il ya très peu de des grecs
en grèce en fait ils puissent selon les
pays et bien vous avez de la dette
par exemple en france vous avez la bm
dans tout ce qui est assurance vie
livrés à tous les produits bancaires
ces deux là c'est de la lette de la
dette française qui est qui est acheté
par ces entités et donc au final qui se
retrouvent dans vos différents
portefeuilles et en face à la question à
deux jardiniers solitaire olivier je
croyais que les banques centrales créent
de l'argent
or à la lumière de ce que j'entends ici
des institutions possèdent la dette des
pays
ce serait donc quelque chose que l'on
peut acheter on dit qu'au japon ce sont
les résidents qui possèdent cette dette
comment peut-on posséder une dette
puisqu'elle est censée simplement être
créés non alors le le au japon j'avais
déjà répondu dans l'émission précédente
ce ne sont plus les japonais qui
détiennent la dette c'est la banque du
japon
c'est la bo j qui la banque centrale
japonaise qui détient non seulement les
dettes mais en plus les hôtes et f les
actions ils achètent c'est bien simple
il faut faut voir qu'il ya deux il ya
deux côtés dans la depp ya celui qui
prête et celui qui emprunte les états
empruntent et les les particuliers les
institutions leur prêtent de l'argent en
achetant ses obligations et ils sont
rémunérés
donc toute l'épargné des ménages va
danser des uns pour pour prêter donc de
l'argent à l'état et à ce moment là
elles sont rémunérés par un taux
d'intérêt donc aujourd'hui le taux
d'intérêt faibles voire négatifs mais
normalement vous avez eu pendant des
années jusqu'à 1000 disent à peu près
2011vous avez huit des dettes qu'il est
rémunéré par aux intérêts qui était de 4
2 5%
on va vous prêter de l'argent le taux
d'intérêt en fait représente le riche
peu vous prenez à prêter de l'argent et
ton que ce risque est rémunéré alors il
est évident quand c'est très très très
risqué pas vous avez un taux d'intérêt
qui est très élevée quand on sait peu
risqué vous avez un taux d'intérêt qui
est très peu élevé
sauf que maintenant les banques
centrales ont annulé ça n'avait plus de
marché c'est les banques centrales qui
détermine le prix en achetant
massivement ses bêtes et donc en mettant
des taux d'intérêt à zéro il faut pas
oublier quand on vous entendez des gens
dire que l il faut tout simplement ne
pas rembourser ses dettes
et bien il ça veut dire eux on va alors
découvrir leur épargne juste un tout
petit peu réfléchir avant de lancer ce
genre d'idée merci à beaucoup les
vielles c'est la fin de cette émission
merci de votre fidélité pour voir ou
revoir notre précédent numéro consacré à
la dette rendez vous sur notre site
internet à l'adresse rt france point mtv
n'oubliez pas donc de poser vos
questions à olivier delamarche avec le
hashtag rta cash
olivier un dernier mot si vous voulez
que le monde d'après soit mieux que le
monde avant je vous dis il faut changer
les principaux acteurs